hello and welcome to the lobby gamespot
weekly video game chat show every
tuesday at 2pm pacific right here on
videogames.com the home of video games
it's true i'm the only place to read
about victims in the internet can you
believe it it's the we're the last one
yeah the rest left yeah i mean some of
them have been writing up articles about
how to pet animals in far cry that's
that's right listen listen so let's get
right into it
petty animals yeah
yeah it's great though primal like i
played a few hours it's really fun it's
cool it's a cool game scott butterworth
hello yes good to have you here thank
you happy to be here uh you've reviewed
a bunch of video games for gamespot yeah
i did like three in a row like last time
i was on the show i talked about
firewatch and then i immediately
reviewed the dying light dlc the
following and then i just finished
reviewing uh plants vs zombies garden
warfare 2 yeah is out today actually
perfect dying light have been there for
a little while i think yeah yeah that
came out a week ago
yeah i believe a week ago today cloud so
we're going to talk about uh two of
those in just a minute uh we're also
going to talk about mike maherty about
far cry primal in a little bit too and
peter brown you're here too hi hi peter
i'm just here to fulfill the the beard
requirement rice
yes that's good which is saying yeah in
fact i was wearing glasses for the first
time in about 10 years yesterday so i'm
glad i didn't wear them today because
yeah it would have been too much it just
would have been the three of them i was
hoping you were going to wear them oh
really yeah i was hoping this was going
to be like a new era of spectacles so
you had a beard that would be perfect
because then we'd have like glasses and
beard oh yeah beer just glass it's like
the nightmare last round of a game of
guess who exactly yeah someone could
create this horrific image of our beards
intertwined for the promo do you guys
call that guess who here yeah it's
called guess it's called guess who oh
yes because there's so many little ones
in it like where's waldo it's called
where's wally yeah in europe
like why is it elevators or lifts
aldo is a respectable name waldo waldo
comparable wally yeah okay compared to
wally cludo cludo you got you guys saw
the clue right i actually yes we have
clue yeah like
colonel mustard with the candlesticks
pluto yeah pluto clue makes sense
because you look for clues when you're
what does pluto mean it's not a real
word is it like clue comma though like
no shorthand one word
made up word pluto i mean come on boggle
like car
shirt boggles the mind doesn't it
board games is like the one area in
which we can
okay actually the one that did really
bother me recently was i was cereal
shopping
and it wasn't lucky charms this time go
on
uh frosted flakes yeah we call them
frosties it's way better
that seems like to be like that that
english like shorthand for thing where
you just like add that that little like
frosty
yeah hey frosties frosty's gone why are
you got any frosties
are cheerios cheeries i love danny's
fake accent i love when you really like
lean into it yeah because then i just
piss off the english people i'm irish
people yeah that's always passed off
there exactly yeah this uh this this uh
linguistic podcast of course this is
also a podcast you can uh listen to us
on the itunes on soundcloud and we're
now on stitcher which apparently i don't
even know what that is people were like
already people were like are you on
stitcher i was like i don't know and
then i typed in putting podcasts on
stitch now when stitcher all right so
you can stitch to your hearts good job
behind the scenes team stitch it up yeah
that was just me oh just good job danny
thanks appreciate it scott and thanks
everyone
thanks everyone who's been reviewing us
as well on uh on on the itunes store uh
the various itunes stores because they
split them up by region uh thank you so
much to jeff ein who said jeff eins who
said my favorite weekly video game live
show is now available in convenient
audio format smart conversational style
great mix of guests at a one stop shop i
couldn't literally could not have
written this better myself
even if i tried a one-stop shop for all
the stuff happening in the world of
video games except petting animals
suspiciously positive yeah i know thanks
jeff
checks in the mail let's get into it for
those who are watching on twitch on
gamespot on youtube i will be in the the
chat uh pulling out your questions
especially for these three segments
about the various games we're going to
talk about so let's uh let's jump right
into it scott you reviewed two zombie
games last week we'll get to the plants
later on that didn't even click they
didn't my brain they were
technically zombie games wow that's
weird that i never put those two
together but yeah you're exactly right
yeah you didn't realize you were hired
as our zombie enthusiast apparently yeah
well in my defense they are extremely
different games i mean pvz is obviously
like very like cute and funny and
family-friendly dying light is very like
it's bleak especially like for anybody
that's finished the dlc like you know
exactly how bleak it gets it's uh pretty
intense they're both they're both great
for for different reasons i really
enjoyed both of them honestly yeah the
following got an eight out of ten yeah
interesting looking expansion i remember
a couple of months ago they like put
this the price up because they'd been
like adding so much to it yeah so it's
1999 now it's like a fully fledged kind
of like almost feels like a standalone
thing very different what they've done
they've you know for a game about
parkour so basically in the middle of
the countryside yeah so like for anybody
that didn't play the original it was
based primary line like a parkour
traversal system it was you know weapon
crafting and zombie killing and parkour
and now this dlc is hey you have a
customizable buggy and can just drive
around the countryside which feels like
the antithesis of parkouring through
buildings and stuff so kind of a weird
design decision which is why it's kind
of amazing that it works so well like
not not only do the driving mechanics
themselves actually function beautifully
it melds with the existing gameplay
really well i mean it builds on the
existing weapon crafting system so like
that all feels very familiar um it's it
all just kind of works in a way um and
it ends up being super fun so what's it
like is sort of
i guess you need to have a good driving
model for a game that's going to be set
outside um in the wilderness what's it
like uh traversing that big open area
what's the buggy feel like uh there's
like upgrades and one not for it as well
yeah that's actually sort of the best
part um so to be clear dying light is
not a standalone it has enough content
that it could have been yeah but it is
an expansion to the existing game so you
carry all everything that you earned in
the original game into the dlc so that
means that if you played to the end of
dying light you're pretty much all the
way leveled up so the nice thing about
the dlc is it gives you this new skill
tree to level up so you have something
to work towards and that skill tree is
your buggy so you're earning upgrades
you're adding stuff to it you're like
equipping it with flamethrowers and uv
headlights with stun zombies things like
that so that whole process of building
up your buggy super satisfying but it
also maintains the sort of survival
element of like you have to go out and
scavenge for gas and scavenge for parts
and you know your buggy will deteriorate
the more you drive it you have to keep
it running um so again that's part of
why it all melts together and works so
well with the existing experience so
yeah upgrades awesome blimp over is
awesome it's it's weird because i was
playing mad max over the the holiday
break uh and i also play half-life 2
basically every year and this kind of
felt i played a little bit of this and i
felt like the highway 17 levels of
half-life 2 mixed with this like like
you're yeah like you're saying
collecting all this resources oh
absolutely i was actually talking with
somebody i think there was even a line
in the review at one point that ended up
getting cut that it's sort of a better
mad max than mad max
because it actually has like the
survival elements and and
the satisfaction of building up the car
and making your own is actually sort of
better than it was in the mad max game
um which was not a terrible game but
it's yeah this dlc kind of nails it
without really
necessarily aiming for that it just kind
of like i said fits with the existing
experience and just becomes mad max on
accident yeah yeah
a game that you loved
that was actually the very first lobby i
ever watched because i i remember being
like oh yeah peter brown guy he's got a
good head and shoulders feel bad because
everyone in the comments hates him
that was i've since gone back and played
my max because i hadn't played my max
you gave i think six out of 10. yeah
like i'm i'm totally with you like it's
it's a totally competent game that's
like
it looks it looks really pretty the
driving was really fun but the sort of
stuff you're describing about the buggy
which should be this sort of like
organic relationship with your car so
you really grow attached to it the game
like forced objectives
through forced upgrades right so you're
like i have to upgrade my buggy this way
or that way to continue the story and it
just felt so prescribed and clinical it
was like i don't know and even the
resource gathering in mad max was not
that
imperative to your success i found yeah
you know whatever i mean
it's it's cool to see that dying lead
did so well especially because it's so
different and they've even said now that
in 2016 they're going to make more
content for the game right because the
following has just done so well for them
yeah it should i mean it's one of my
favorite pieces of dlc like maybe ever
uh it just because it does something
that's both new i mean
the way phrased it in the reviews it's
both it's at once distinct from and in
sync with the original experience i
think that's what makes it so impressive
yeah that it does something new and it
works and it feels natural i like all of
those elements combined with something
that's just fun like driving around and
mowing down zombies like i don't really
know what more you could want at a dlc
yeah i mean dlc usually just like adds
something to
you know a sort of a base game that's
like just complementary almost all right
or fits in really neatly whereas this
almost seems like they just had this
whole idea a different game just like
screw it let's just do this and it works
um i mean it wasn't perfect you still
got an eight out of ten but you know i
mean i highly recommend it and it
attended my mind is like an excellent
score what was the combat like
considering like this was a game that
was based around melee yeah about like a
really difficult sort of you know in
dying light when you use weapons they
break apart especially to start when you
haven't sort of upgraded your your
character's ability to like i don't know
the durability of the weapons like stuff
falls apart really quickly what's it
like suddenly having a car you can
basically just mow down zombies in well
like i said so the car does break down
too so you're not completely off the
hook um like the more the more you drive
off-road and the more zombies you hit
like things will just start to fall
apart
to the point that eventually your buggy
will just like not be drivable anymore
if you're not repairing it actively um
so it doesn't make the game like too
easy it doesn't really break the game um
and and really the the new setting kind
of changes the way you have to approach
combat because you're right in the
original game it was very melee focused
you were very up close and personal and
uh in this having so much space it means
both
not having cover anymore not having a
convenient means of escape you can't
just like climb up on a van and like be
above the fray and find a way out you
know you actually have no choice but to
engage the zombies that are after you or
to like get your buggy and run um so it
does change the way you approach combat
you end up uh using ranged weapons a lot
more you actually there's this great
tactical crossbow you get as you play
through the dlc that's phenomenal but
also if you still have any firearms from
the original game those work great i
highly recommend them they're much safer
than trying to melee like a huge hoard
of zombies that you can't get away from
anymore
um so yeah it fundamentally changes the
way you approach combat without actually
doing any like introducing any new
combat mechanics right which is another
reason that i think the dlc works so
well yeah it's really quite an
achievement uh thanks to everyone who's
been sending questions via the chat uh
yes as as you can see the folks in the
back are just throwing up all your
questions so please by all means get
them in there at daniel dawar if you
want me to see them uh here on my laptop
as well uh let's talk briefly about what
getting too much into the the story
stuff uh how is the story does it pay
off yeah i mean uh i've seen some
comments so i don't want to spoil the
ending because it really goes in like a
pretty pretty gnarly direction um a lot
of people really hated it i admired that
they made a bold choice with the way
they wrap it up but the sort of premise
is donald trump's president at the end
yes great it's terrifying zombie donald
trump devices yeah no so donald trump
zombies oh yeah
um
speaking of brains
um let's see oh colts yeah so the basic
premise is um at the end at the end of
dying live from he hasn't finished it
like you're still in a city overrun with
zombies like i won't spoil how that game
wraps up but at the end of the game like
you're still in a city there are still
zombies so this dlc starts with a random
person from outside of town showing up
and being like hey there's a way out and
by the way there's also a place where
people are immune to this epidemic okay
i'm gonna die now and then he dies and
you take his map and find your way out
and then you're suddenly in the
countryside and you discover that
there's like this whole cold situation
and you have to infiltrate the cult to
try to figure out how people are like
immune to the zombie virus and you have
like a standing with them
yeah you basically have to earn their
trust because they're very mistrustful
of outsiders they don't know who you are
they don't you know want to reveal
anything to you and of course like the
the whole rabbit hole of this cult the
whole conspiracy goes very deep and so
you just peel back you know the onion
layers um but so that does mean and this
is one of my biggest problems with the
dlc actually uh you end up doing a lot
of just fetch quests as favors to earn
trust it's like oh gee whiz i don't want
to tell you about this thing so why
don't you go talk to this guy on the
opposite side of the map for no reason
so there's a lot of that which is
unfortunate um but in terms of narrative
payoff it does actually work like it's
annoying having to do so many fetch
quests but at least there's a compelling
reason to do them and like there is sort
of a payoff and it does kind of go
somewhere and i appreciate that it
becomes a conspiracy thriller rather
than just a generic you know oh there
are zombies we have to kill them survive
you know like every other zombie game so
it's a pretty novel approach for an
apocalypse style setting which is cool i
just think it'd be great if there's a
zombie game where you had to try your
best to actually get bitten but the
zombies just don't want anything to do
with you so you're like going out of
your way like zombie dating come on yeah
like driver every time you try and knock
somebody down they just go
get out of the way and before we wrap
this up i got some questions from the
chat coming in here yeah uh mammoth eu
saying uh dying light the following is
exactly what dlc should look like such
great value for money it is 19.99 i know
it's 60 bucks with the base game as well
they're selling yeah so actually there's
a special edition like definitive
edition of the entire game that you can
buy for 60 dollars which does include
the following dlc so if you never played
the original that's probably your best
bet because you can upgrade and play
through the original game and then carry
all that into the dlc and it's all in
one convenient package cool uh shooty78
says how long is the following because
name is shooty seventy shootie78 that's
awesome you see like shooters he's
38 years 30 something years old 38 yeah
yeah we're editors
words words not numbers
scores are dumb words are great uh yeah
so i mean you can beat the sort of
campaign of the dlc in probably about 10
hours okay um so it's pretty substantial
but there's also plenty of stuff to just
go and find like people are already
uncovering all these easter eggs all
throughout the world map so you can just
kind of drive around and focus on
finding upgrades and crafting stuff and
discovering hidden areas things like
that so all things considered for
completionist like there's probably like
20 hours of content to this dlc which is
substantial and uh last question here
from lord
the lmv uh is parkour still a big part
of the game yeah actually so i mean you
spend a lot of time commuting between
locations but once you get to those
locations very often there is room to
kind of parkour and you can still
incorporate it in combat like there are
boss encounters that happen in the kind
of enclosed areas and if you're good at
parkour you can use that to your
advantage to you know avoid dying
um and co-op is still a thing by the way
for anybody that's wondering you can
still play all of this in co-op cool
your buddies can actually jump on the
back of your buggy and you can like do
you know ride around and bug you
together it's great your very own chum
buckets yeah
you can just kick them off and keep
driving there's a distraction right you
don't have to outrun the bears get out
around the guy next to you
bear zombie you know nice yeah i like it
ah that's it dying like the following
it's out it's been out already but it's
out now on uh on pc i guess uh on pc or
let's see pc xbox one and ps4 oh wow all
right yeah i forgot it was out on
consoles
it looks really good as well it does
looks good it really does yeah and
actually the new setting allows it to so
i mean it's it's bright and yeah
coastline and water it's very nice
super good thanks so much scott
absolutely talking to spanish uh how are
you doing peter i'm good
sorry you're so good it's your turn now
no dude i mean you've got plenty to say
so i'm gonna let you do it i'm just
gonna sit here and try to look pretty
well here's something both of you can
talk about because both of you are
uh virtual reality
fans evangelists i don't know your folks
who have had experience with vro more
than most people here in the office yeah
scott you recently went over and played
with the htc vive the yes valve vr um
up in was it in seattle in seattle yeah
cool and obviously peter you've been
using them but you had a really
interesting experience last year where
you
earlier this year where you used the
oculus and the htc vive within like five
minutes of each other yeah yeah very
illuminating
would you love to hear about it yeah in
a second because yes we've just had the
news that uh the vibe is going to be
starting pre-orders in sometime in april
apparently okay so you can start
pre-ordering on february 29th it'll
start shipping in april okay so 29th
that's less than a week ago yeah yeah
it's monday and then people will start
getting their systems in april so like
that's right around the corner it's
happening but they do need to pony up
eight hundred dollars yes for the
package but let's talk about the value
there because the oculus rift headset is
600 if i'm correct 600 and with that you
get the xbox one pad which almost feels
superfluous in a weird way like i feel
like the people who would be buying that
might already have that but yeah
probably in the headset right and that's
yes with the vive you get the headset
two of their their controllers which are
new brand new built for vr they really
do make those experiences feel distinct
and special and you get the cameras that
you use for positional tracking which
are like those like four little
doohickey
lighthouse sensors yeah and and all of
those combined just make like a really
good experience for vr
that oculus is like close to hitting
yeah they're just not there yet because
you can't you can walk around a small
amount of space with the oculus rift on
but you can't do the full room
experience and they don't have the tech
that htc has put into their headset
either that will detect when something's
in front of you and give you sort of
like a ghostly image of it so you don't
bump into it yeah but also they're not
taking you out of the game it's just
like a subtle nudge like by the way
there's a wall there
so it doesn't break immersion either is
this like you know obviously people are
saying oh my god we're so used to
spending you know 400 for a console or
500 for a console and you know maybe pcs
obviously cost more a lot more um
do you think people are disappointed at
this price point are we are we now at
the stage where the like sort of the
internet community is the gaming
community has kind of figured out that
okay actually vr is going to cost this
much money no matter what uh i kind of
look at it this way right like whenever
a gpu manufacturer announces their best
card you know it costs somewhat similar
to what people are going to be paying
for these headsets
and frankly if you were to take vr below
the high-end experience right now you
would have something that is not really
desirable so yes it's the only option
but it's a reasonable option when you
consider the sort of the envelope that
exists for this technology right now you
don't want to be at the bottom you want
to be at the top right okay yeah yeah so
i mean that's that's why i don't feel
too bad about it also it's you know
these are the first headsets that are
hitting the market that are offering
something that is better than just a a
base level experience so you can say you
used vr they're offering things that
allow you to actually engage with games
in a way that does feel different and
does feel really good yeah in fact let's
just talk about the games we're here
game spot let's talk about video games i
feel like when we talk about vr half the
time it's always about tech demos i mean
yesterday they released their tech demo
thing on uh over steam as well where you
can
people have been actually data mining
that for some really interesting
half-life three stuff did you see any of
that i saw something always yeah yeah
just
like a head crab reference here hl3
there like okay well apparently yeah
half-life through some sort of quest
system you gotta imagine this people at
valve are just doing that yeah do you
think so just like just messing around
at this point or even just joke with
each other internally oh good one steve
yeah i see what you did there
hl3 actually stands for like hollow lamp
three yeah yeah yeah
i don't know that's exactly right
half life three aside uh you were up
there you played 12 games in a row yes
this was just a couple weeks ago uh
steam so um valve hosted with the steam
vr showcase which was basically here are
12 games that are all coming out this
year coming to htc vive right so
everything i played is going to be out
at some point within the next like six
to eight months most likely cool um yeah
and and what was cool about it is as you
mentioned you know previously we've seen
a lot of tech demos but what i was
playing up in seattle were actually
games like games that i could see myself
sitting down and playing
what's this guy uh
that's raw data oh that is raw data that
one actually played a little more
recently that's also a vive game
it's sort of a combination like tower
defense slash like standing light gun
shooter okay uh you're basically waiting
for
a computer to like download some stuff
for you and you have to defend the
computer from robot assassins who are
trying to stop you so you're basically
your motion controllers your guns and
you can get a bow or a shotgun yeah i
like the sword situation here actually
in fact there's a couple of games you're
playing here i see like tilt brush
budget cuts job simulator how many of
these games are games where you were
standing in one position and
uh quite i mean definitely a few uh what
was interesting though is that they all
did something really different i mean of
the 12 games that i that i wouldn't saw
in seattle each one was very i mean they
were all very different and they were
almost all different genres there were a
couple shooters but other than that it
was it was pretty pretty interesting i
mean there was a mini golf game there
was like a you know a couple sort of
puzzly games that approached puzzles in
different ways
a couple shooters a stealth game you
know a top-down god mode game just a
bunch of different stuff and and like i
said it was all stuff that i could
actually see myself playing like they
were real games not just tech demos
which was what was so exciting about it
stuff i could anticipate and like want
to play uh i guess last question on this
coming away from the game stuff is that
there was a
mobile world congress i think is on
barcelona at the moment um was that
where zuckerberg was on stage with yeah
samsung was doing their press conference
and they gave everyone in the audience
the gear vr headset which is the thing
that you can take one of your various
samsung phones and dock into it and get
pretty good vr oh one of my samsung
phones yeah okay
which one will i put in well one of many
yeah i mean i know you all have a few
right i mean at e3 probably right yeah
um yeah and there was this image that
was sort of like we've hit this point in
vr now where all our worst fears come
true where you're gonna be our headset
and all of a sudden mark zuckerberg is
walking around with a goofy smile and a
tight t-shirt
my army yeah the tweet the tweet that i
saw was like uh
black mirror season three or yeah
exactly that's the image yeah yeah yeah
very
creepy very yeah for the podcast series
i'm sure every time zuckerberg vr you'll
look at that challenge yeah yeah but our
at least with the htc vive sort of
coming back to it are they looking have
they
you know
sort of talked about getting into that
weird space of oh this is also like a
communication machine which is very much
like what i feel i experienced with the
oculus right touch demo and with the
reason why facebook bought it right i
don't think i think it's a good reason
part of the reason why i bought it i
don't think we're going to see like
really dedicated first-party social apps
like the way we imagine them now i think
it's going to be sort of a slow build up
to something that is like a really
concerted focused effort on like this is
the social platform
for vr um so if anything i don't think
you're going to see valve do too much
with it maybe they'll integrate steam in
a way they are integrating sort of local
social stuff where you can like get
phone calls in the vive headset which is
which is a good thing
um but yeah i i don't see anyone any one
company really going all in on social
stuff right now because that's the first
way to like trigger fears that people
are already expressing before these
things are even out right that somehow
this is going to like remove them from
reality and like blah blah i think
people need to get way more comfortable
with this technology before they're
willing to like
feel comfortable interfacing on a
regular basis with a headset on yeah but
it does work really well as you saw uh
at gamescom yeah the oculus touch thing
that was the one that turned me into oh
yeah this [ __ ] is incredible exactly
yeah which is hard to
yeah it's an uphill battle trying to
explain that to people who have never
tried it because it's like you can't
communicate the sensation it's like
holding a wee mouse like that [ __ ] like
the dorkiest piece of [ __ ] in the world
and then i remember like playing it in
in like they had like a wii station it
was actually in like a supermarket in
birmingham in the north of england i was
like that
the bull ring itself itself and i was
there and i literally had to go to
tennis and i was like oh my gosh yeah so
i guess maybe this will help people
actually one question here the last one
that's um uh we'll actually give it to
josh shaw who's inside uh helping direct
the show uh he says i can't wear a vr
headset for uh maybe for over maybe an
hour before feeling bad you played games
for like a whole day what was that like
yeah so the schedule for the event that
i attended was it was six hours uh and i
played games in 15 15-minute bursts for
like a cumulative total of three hours
of play time uh and so just playing 15
minutes and taking the headset off i was
fine the only motion sickness i ever
experienced was uh playing not not eve
valkyrie watch the other one um
the other space oh elite dangerous elite
dangerous thank you yeah and that was
only because like i was driving a buggy
around like a low gravity planet like
flipping off dunes and stuff so i was
doing it to myself um so i was fine i
did find it
every time i took the headset off it was
more and more difficult to reacclimate
to reality like after having so many
times taking headset off and on i kind
of had to actually consciously remind
myself by then like oh okay headsets off
back in the real world
um so i mean it's it can be a little
exhausting but i think that you know the
more people use it the more they'll get
used to it and uh honestly i think i
think it'll be fine i didn't have too
much trouble with it um but then again
i'm not generally prone to motion
sickness or anything like that i i
didn't find it uncomfortable or anything
physically uncomfortable i wonder if
that's a thing where people are like
gonna i don't want to spend 800 just in
case like i don't know if it's going to
make me sick at home i'm really hoping
for like the re-emergence of like cyber
cafes you can just go and like try this
for a while right like you know what i'm
talking about a bunch of stories sense
you're going to see it in in airplanes i
think yeah that's not too far off
especially in first class but i think
give it five years you're gonna start
seeing like
maybe if not that like you know you're
seeing like a lot of uh smart devices
and airports now like at little tables
where people are waiting granted hygiene
is a problem but
uh yeah i mean you could see vr headsets
and scenarios like that as well yes i
remember uh it was a teresa duranger who
was created um the canon brawl he was an
artist in that game they're making
they've made a great vr game as well i
forget what it's called bizarre uh and
she has a problem flying she's like
deathly afraid of flying and she
basically went on a across america trip
and used her um i guess it was the
samsung vr she used uh or samsung called
the gear viewer sorry uh and it like
completely mitigated her her sickness or
her like her anxiety so yeah yeah it's
weird it's going to be interesting to
see where this stuff ends up uh thank
you both for coming in and talking about
virtual reality uh let us know in the
chat if you're interested in picking up
an htc or an oculus which one spin that
extra 200 bones or whatever it is uh for
for the extra sensors let us know in the
chat and the comments below
gentlemen
i'm excited about the future of your
it's coming it's a little bit outside my
price my my price point maybe by
christmas maybe a little bit more at the
time yeah yeah it'll get there yeah but
by future you mean like two or three
years from now i'm also excited for that
yeah in terms of the next six to eight
months it's a little iffier but we'll
see yeah there's gonna be a lot of
people getting rid of their sofas
craigslist
uh let's get back on the zombie train
shall we sure why not scott you're here
hello you are the zombie master you're
still talking about zombies yeah we're
not done with you yet almost two years
to the day from the release of the first
plants vs zombie games activision have
put out it's a shooter franchise that
they're running that they're not putting
out every year so that's a that's it's
nice wonderful and it's a shooter
franchise based on a what started as a
flash tower defense game so like kudos
to them for like effectively spinning
this universe into a shooter franchise
like in a way that is cute and fun and
interesting and actually funny yeah like
that's pretty impressive honestly like
not awful like that i guess candy crush
shooter
candy candy warfare coming soon yes
hopefully not uh yeah it's far from
awful um i i enjoyed it quite a bit i
mean i had a few problems with it uh
interestingly so of the three reviews
that i mentioned at the top of the show
here uh firewatch uh the dying light dlc
and plants versus zombies garden warfare
for two uh i got the most hate for my
garden warfare 2 review which was sort
of interesting really yes so the first
game people were kind of cautious or
surprised i think by how fun it was or
how well received it was sort of waiting
to see that train wreck comments put
into the station but wait why were
people
uh i think it's one of those games that
you know the audience isn't massive but
the people who love it really love it
and were a little
defensive or upset with me for not
loving it as much as they do i think
what scored again uh so we got a seven
out of ten okay which as i always say
it's not a bad score i mean it's
literally a good score yeah it says so
right under the number i mean we're not
ign we actually score we use the whole
scale yeah i mean you know
throwing shade there danny but i mean
it's kind of true that on like if you go
to like reddit or neogaf there's there's
an ongoing joke of like oh it's horrible
the graphics are bad 9 out of 10 ign
like right like you'll see that
everywhere so we're kind of actively
trying to not
i mean into the metacritic trap of like
yeah a seven is mediocre like you go to
metacritic and the seven is he has the
yellow background like it's bad like no
yeah like we are attempting to use the
whole scale a seven is good it says good
i know that that doesn't fit with
certain people's perceptions
of numbers
uh but like i always say seven's a good
score games can arrive at the same score
for very different reasons like a
seventh one game it's not the same as a
seven for another you know you mean they
don't add up like all the various
features to like once no no no you start
at 10 and you take away for everyone
that's not that's right i was talking
with someone in the comments about that
and explaining like look that's not how
we do scores we kind of just start it
neutral and then experience the game and
then you know synthesize all of our
thoughts into a number at the end like
we're not knocking stuff off in some
kind of mathematical way we don't start
at 10 and work our way down like we're
just trying to deliver a number that
speaks to the overall quality of the
game and this is another thing i always
tell people like read the text like i
spend so much more time on the text than
on the score like i think very deeply
about the number that i'm getting the
game the number is literally the final
part of the equation yeah we never
really start with a number unless it's
something that is just so phenomenal or
so busy yes the times i've only ever
seen during the review process uh
the the number come into the equation is
either the reviewer telegraphing that yo
this might be a 10 or this is real
stinker does the text reflect what i'm
thinking of giving it but yeah that's
sort of i wish we could change the
word under one to stinker
what is it now
nothing thinker abysmal is one of them
yeah that's just a great word yeah it is
good yeah i don't know totally agree
that the seven should be good says
estran 23. thank you all right let's get
let's get back on the on the rails here
right
yeah garden warfare 2. so this is a game
it's got a single prayer campaign it's
got a multiplayer um
thing going on as well and then it's got
its little co-op sort of part of it
let's talk about single player first of
all not too deep it sounds yeah it's not
great um so this this was an interesting
one because the the first garden warfare
was a 40 game it did not have really any
solo content at all uh much less than
actual campaign so it was sort of a big
deal that this game actually does have a
campaign the only issue is that it's
very content light and the content that
exists is just sort of a remix of other
content that exists elsewhere in the
game right so the game is structured
around a hub world now so instead of
just a menu system you actually inhabit
the sort of physical space and there are
portals to the different game modes and
you can wander around and find stuff in
the hub world um so that's pretty cool
but the way the the campaign works is
typically a campaign mission will be
like hey go to this location in the hub
world and fetch this thing again back to
just like meaningless fetch quests yeah
so there's not like dedicated
environments or like set pieces or
really much storytelling like you'll get
some framing text exposition dumps right
at the beginning of each mission and
then you'll just go do a thing you'll
come back and yeah you're done
that's like literally every mission the
only exception is when you get thrown
into a garden ops or graveyard ops match
which is the game's cooperative mode
right you and three other people or
three ai uh fighting against waves of
enemies while trying to defend the
central you know location
so it's you know it's either a game mode
that exists or go find stuff in the hub
world it's not it's not great um and
people had actually asked me like would
the game have gotten a better score if
it hadn't had single player at all and
the answer is no because that would have
solved the problem of the single player
being not great but it would have
created a new problem of there being
sort of like a dearth of content or
something extra to sort of games entice
you to yeah so like games that have
single player
sometimes a problem peter
we'll get to street fighter a little bit
maybe yeah yeah street fighter is an
interesting one um but yeah so the solo
content not great um and and for me i
really enjoyed the multiplayer quite a
bit but it wasn't quite enough to
compensate for the fact that the solo
cam solo campaign was like just not just
not very good garden up stuff is that
interesting
is really fun actually one of the best
aspects of this new game is you can
actually use uh ai allies for every mode
now in the previous game that wasn't
always the case okay so you can actually
jump into the cooperative mode with
computer-controlled players and actually
swap a hot swap among them so like
whatever four characters you choose to
bring in you can actually jump between
them at will that's cool which is really
cool so if you're playing by yourself it
makes it a lot more like winnable
basically and kind of it adds a new sort
of fun dynamic so that was really cool
i'm really glad they did that um you'd
also play a lot of the multiplayer modes
solo by bringing in ai which is also
really cool yeah well i mean that's yeah
that sort of adds something to the
single-player elements of the game yeah
um let's talk about the multiplayer
software as well they've bumped up the
amount of characters it's up to 14 now
three new characters for either side yes
correct like okay is it still like that
seems like a lot of like yeah characters
to sort of understand like coming in
like we were playing overwatch again
recently and you really have to like
spend time to figure out what everyone
does how does the balancing act feel in
this yeah god it's uh i mean it's i
wouldn't call it overwhelming but i
think it's important to understand that
those 14 characters are all extremely
distinct from one another it's not like
oh like you kind of have a medic class
and ah you kind of have like the
grenadier guys like no no like they have
different movement speeds different
levels of health different you know jump
heights different primary weapons like
they are mechanically extremely distinct
from one another so learning how each
matchup kind of works is crucial to
being good at the game and is there some
like variety within those classes then
as well there is um so there are 110
total
character variants right and each of
those variants has something that's
mechanically distinct about them um so
that's the 14 base characters but then
you'll so like there's pea shooter right
then there's also rock p who's like a
like heavier more armored version of
that character who has like less ammo
before he has to reload but also has
more health uh so like that's sort of an
example of a variant on a base character
there are a hundred and ten of those uh
it takes an eternity to unlock all of
them but uh
yeah it's again it makes matchups in the
game super important because you have to
know what you're up against and how to
sort of counteract the strategy that you
that you've encountered on the
battlefield uh it lends a lot of
strategic depth and it actually makes
the game much richer than you might
expect for something that looks so cute
but
the fact that everything unlocks so
slowly is is pretty frustrating right
and trying to sort of manage all of that
is also a little overwhelming without
sort of
at least having some kind of background
with with the original game because if
you don't know what the classes do and
how they interact like
you're gonna lose a lot online it's so
strange it's almost like remember when
viva pinata came in you're like oh
they're making this like game that's you
know they're we're launching a cartoon
show alongside of it and it's going to
be for kids and rare are making it and
then it's like the hardest [ __ ]
thing in the world right it's just a
little bit like that right it's like
yeah i'm super curious like is there an
audience that's missing out on this game
because of the way it's dressed probably
yeah because it everyone seems to rave
about it but i look at it just purely
just like superficial you know uh
perspective and it's just like i just
don't i don't want that
the design looks incredible i mean it
looks yes but it doesn't speak to me
necessarily but when i hear about the
gameplay it's like well [ __ ] like i
would do that yeah it's it's super
inventive just like the different
types of characters and the different
sort of mechanics built into these
characters i mean it's not just oh
shooty shooty bang bang everyone dead
like you could you know there's a
character that burrows underground can
like eat characters from underneath like
there's just all these unique mechanics
you wouldn't encounter typically in an
online shooter which to me is the core
strength of this game like that is the
biggest reason to play this game it is a
well-made robust shooter that does
inventive things with its mechanics that
other games aren't even attempting so
that's to me what makes it a good game
there are other things that hold it back
but if there's a reason to play garden
warfare 2 that's that's it like the
mechanical diversity the incredible
creativity of its characters and just
like the process of learning how all of
that interacts online it's really
interesting there you go scott thank you
so much uh garden warfare plants vs
zombies garden warfare 2 to give its
full title uh today in north america out
on friday uh worldwide so you go what's
that on it's on pc x bone and
playstation 4. correct yeah there you go
the triangle the trifecta as it were
actually one interesting comment that
came in here from blessed ignorant in
the in the chat uh we're conditioned to
think that eight below eight is not
worth the time or money perhaps due to
time and financial constraints that's a
good point maybe we all have like
there's like that internal barometer
where you're like you know what if
something gets an eight or a nine or a
ten i'm like that's what that's like
willing to take a punt on whereas seven
makes it a little bit more uncomfortable
it's like oh i don't know that's the end
result but what's the actual like source
of that i don't know that if it's
necessarily time and money that make you
feel like a seven isn't great like when
did we learn that a seven means it's not
worth your precious little time yeah
maybe only if there's like a game that's
got an ace sitting right beside it a
shiner
like that idea that cause like that's
one of the things i feel like i've i
actually lost this when i started
working at a game store because then i
had access to all these cheap games
which is that i used to be a lot more
precious about like oh i can buy that
and not buy that and then when i had
this like whatever 30 discount in
gamestop it was like oh this is amazing
like i can get whatever hell i want how
many times did you base your purchasing
decisions on reviews
pretty often yeah but but but with a
very underlying bias of what i thought
beforehand yeah well yeah of course
reviews were like the the last hurdle
where it was like i kind of feel like
this is something i want already and
then reviews is like just making sure
that it's not like a total train wreck
it's kind of validating that you're
making the right choice in a way like
you kind of know what you want to do
what you need to confirm that you're not
about to do something stupid yeah yeah
god bless confirmation bias so like
seven
maybe i don't know peter actually made a
really interesting point long ago to me
that's really stuck with me which is
that it's really not up to reviewers to
determine the value of a dollar anyway i
mean so if you're you know working in a
game store and you know you don't have a
ton of excess income to just throw at
games you're gonna be a little more
cautious about the games that you
actually buy but that's not everyone
there are plenty of people who you know
work here in san francisco who have tons
of extra income who can just like throw
60 bucks in a game without even thinking
about it so [ __ ] hoverboard
oh there's so many oh so many but so
it's not up to us to decide that like oh
well if you know we give it a seven that
means no one's gonna buy it it's like
well
people have different
thresholds for what they're willing to
spend money on so i mean that's for us
it's it's not a productive way to look
at scoring a game yeah for sure the
battle continues i know
the world of video game reviews i'm very
we're very brave
yes it's a hard job somebody's got to do
it we're super lucky uh let's get mike
mccarty in for a second because we're
going to talk about just cause 3 right
before far cry primal scott butterworth
a pleasure as ever happy to be here
you've probably got about 12 more games
to review so
are you reviewing editing right now not
at the moment but there are a couple big
ones coming out i want to spoil anything
but i had a couple couple of reviews
that are going to be in the next couple
weeks that'll awesome keep me busy all
right we'll have you back then thanks so
much absolutely appreciate it hearty get
your ass in here
got a sweet cup gotta swap out cups as
well yeah
my goodness
cheers
there you go yeah yeah tie again yeah
got steve bruhl here that's uh for the
folks on the video feed he's got a quote
on it i found it a flea market
you found this at a flea market you
bought a cup at a flea market yeah the
treasure island flea market it's not
like a used cup it's this guy who prints
pop culture [ __ ] on
blocks of wood or cups or
so andy walsh sorted goods yes yes art
now andy warhol jr i always wonder about
treasure island for the treasure island
is the island between the two bridges in
the bay it's radiated as well it's
radiated
do you not know why no no one lives
there i know it's irradiated yeah
there's a [ __ ] college campus on it
there's i know there's a bunch of things
there that people participate in but
yeah there's like nuclear waste stored
underground there it's like it's not
it's not a joke it's why that place is
so you were the one that invited me to
that flea market yeah well
i'm not gonna drink out of this cup
anymore yeah you're [ __ ] a radiated
cup that's not bad
in terms of the stories of a radiated
nonsense uh werner goff who helped us
put some of the lighting in this room
and helped us like put it together and
was very involved in game spot uh live
productions of old he went to a oh right
do you remember yeah i remember hearing
about he went to pripyat for like a
stalker shadow of chernobyl like press
event or whatever and they basically
like brought them out to pripyat and
they wore hazmat suits and he [ __ ]
kept his he like they were like throw
these away and he brought it back on the
plane and then he had it in like a foot
locker beside his desk at home and he
started to get these pains in his knees
after like five months
uh and then yeah he brought it into work
and somebody ryan mack or somebody had
like had a geiger character and they
went like
yeah and i was like totally off the
chain boy off the off the thanks we had
to throw thanks warner there you go that
should get something we should get it on
that cup okay i'll geiger count this
thing and then i'll see how mad i should
be at you for bringing me out there
there's other reasons you should be mad
at me but oh i always think of like a if
a tsunami or something hit san francisco
treasure island would be [ __ ] gone
because it's so flat and now there's no
waste under it i hear yeah okay i'm
surprised know that i live in oakland
that's gonna get churned up and brought
to my house
isn't it isn't like half the peninsula
already like on landfill sure yeah
actually yeah francisco is yeah this
building sand dunes and stuff yeah
detroit i think you were just about to
mock me then you're like oh it's
actually he's right
no
i don't always mock you i don't always
joke
uh yeah you always do that's why we have
you here mike maherty thank you for
joining us thanks for having me in the
lobby today first of all we're to talk
about far cry in a little hot second but
first of all i want to talk to you about
sky fortresses oh man so just fighter
jet humans yeah just cause three is dlc
is coming out you can turn rico into an
f-16 or whatever yeah it turns a wing
suit into just it's powered like by
bavarium that substance that you're
trying to it's radioactive oh really
substance that you're trying to fight
over in uh
in the base game and now it just powers
your wing suit so you have like infinite
not infinite boost but you could stay in
the air for
however long you want you have like a
chain gun on one shoulder missile
launcher on the other you can do
strafing runs and then turn on a dime
kind of
literally that's crazy yeah what is it
is it fun yeah it's really fun what else
do you do in it like what is the dlc
does it there's a sky fortress
does it plug into just three proper is
it like a separate mission there's a
certain mission that you go to to like
upgrade the wing suit and then you can
just the sky fortress is actually
floating you can get to it from wherever
you can use that oh wow here it is you
can use this say for instance somebody
like me who has only like played i've
only unlocked half the bases in the game
i haven't touched the big island yet if
i was to get this dlc do you think i'd
be able to use that suit to take out all
those you would be able to get it soon
yeah um you would probably need
a little more few more upgrades to
actually take on the sky fortress
because that was like an upper level
outpost um i don't know if you'll see
gameplay of it but it so the sky
fortress is divided into two of those
outposts so there's the bow section and
the stern which are both have their own
things you need to destroy and uh
there's like an underbelly to it where a
lot of its power cores are that you need
to take out but and it's also
the main enemies are all drones so
there's these drone dispensers you can
get your own one to like kind of fly
around support you and distract enemies
and shoot them and uh
yeah the majority of people i was are
not people the majority of enemies i was
fighting were drones from the eden
corporation they didn't tell me too much
about the story so i don't know what's
going on with it for like two hours did
that seem like about the length of it no
they said it should take you it could
take you like four without if you do all
the story missions i guess um i was also
still getting acclimated to it again so
it's taking me longer than it might if i
had been playing just cause three right
before a lot uh you know i played about
20 something hours back when i was
reviewing it but since then i haven't
been able to play it too much so it's
kind of rusty cool uh it's out in march
fortress unspecified date in march and
then two months after that will be the
land base it's like air land and sea dlc
did you turn into a motorcycle
it's like uh
you
no it's a mech actually it's like it's a
giant floating mech hover map and then
after that two months after that will be
the c1 which is a sea heist yeah you're
a surfboard and a machine gun
you ride around a dolphin with chain
guns perfect oh
just realized no i didn't mean that i
swear all right did sky did it seem fun
like yeah really fun uh especially if
you played a lot of just cause it might
be the thing to bring you back in
because i've played like 20 hours and i
haven't i've only done half the [ __ ]
game oh yeah so this should be i mean
just it makes it even more ridiculous
than it already is so and it's they're
making they have no qualms about that
they're just going for it excellent
which i appreciate looking forward to
seeing more thanks so much a great um
twitch message here from shapowi says
muppets treasure island is the best
treasure island fair enough that's good
maybe strong nuclear waste made them
into muppets that's a muppet star it's
not quite a mob that's not quite a
puppet but man
simpsons no no
i love the simpsons but that one flew
over my head that's pete's thing is to
bring up like pop culture references he
knows i won't get that's not true i just
forget how young you are i'm not you're
like four years older than me i'll be 31
in a couple weeks i'll be 29 in a couple
weeks so that's not that's not
twenty-nine you're almost twenty-nine no
i'm sorry i'm just kidding that's
amazing you've done so many born movies
and you're not even thirty years old ty
just said that today he said he saw the
martian he's like yeah so i was hanging
on my girlfriend and mike
and i was like oh i get it it's uh it's
a common thing i hear uh i like it it's
good comparison my girlfriend recently
told me uh she said i really like your
glasses it stops your face looking like
a potato
thanks babe that's great yeah double
whammy there as well for the irish
yeah and also the color on this the
camera makes it look like i'm wearing a
green shirt as well i just can't stop it
i'm just a potato
do potato do potatoes wear
green shirts they're so grimace and yell
with their hands yeah yeah exactly
they've all got gray hair as well okay
cool let's talk about video games let's
talk about video games from the past
okay not five years ago you see where
i'm going with this not ten years ago
how many ten thousand years so long
before our lord and savior jesus christ
walked the uh walk the earth uh what
initially seemed like a sort of a blood
dragon style spin-off game and it turns
out is actually a a really good far
quicker maybe probably the best far cry
game you know in a little while maybe
yeah uh mike mccarty so committed to
your
evaluation maybe probably in a while
maybe yeah yeah just sitting on this
fence just whoo just thought i'd
interrupt you real quick there
yeah far cry primal it's uh it's out now
it's uh well sorry it's out on consoles
let's get this out of the way first of
all have you actually played the pc
version yet i have not no i played both
xbox one and ps4 both which perform
equally not good yeah equally well they
both way too many adverbs the ps4
version i played the xbox one version i
saw it when playing yeah looks this
looks the same they both run well yeah
yeah they like 30 frames a second was
the only thing that was making me think
oh i'd love to see this on pc sure they
never like we got access to the game i
feel like a good while ago it was like
late last week console sorry yes on
camera yeah but nothing but pc
i guess it's not out until next week so
right uh no i've not been able to play
it yet but i will soon and then update
the review yeah just to make sure it's
not
totally
screwed yep yeah which you could go
either way you know um but yeah let's
talk about what we have played uh primal
it's a pretty
cool game yeah it's uh
it was surprising because i i think i
shared the sentiment with a lot of
people that maybe somewhere along the
way they would try to make it more like
they would kind of have to compensate
for the fact that you know it's a
primitive time and you don't have
grenade launchers and rocket launchers i
think i kept expecting
to be like to have some sort of wooden
machine gun contraption to kind of just
like like hamstring in there that's not
the shoe string yeah what is the phrase
i'm looking for it doesn't matter
doesn't matter we got it yeah figure you
know what i'm saying uh i mean they
don't even speak english in this video
game so don't worry about it all right
that's that's one of the
great things about this game they really
stick to the setting they establish it's
not i mean like historically correct for
the people watching this video you know
yeah for the people watching the video
version you literally said that as the
b-roll had uh i believe rob handley
running around on the back of a mountain
lion yeah perfect uh also you always
have a map
yeah also map and uh and you can control
owls that drop b bombs on people i
the best thing i've done and i capture
my ps4 you know that you know people
always say it's like a running joke
about three and four and now primals
that the eagles are annoying because
they'll just swoop on you
an eagle was flying at me as i was
stealing it was a quest to take
like rare eagle feathers and to craft
something specific he's flying at me i
took on my club smoked it
he just kept going into the cliff behind
me and ragdoll it was the most
satisfying thing ever i had a moment
last week when i did the nail playing
where there was an eagle in the distance
picking up a ghost
like flying around here someone told me
this yeah i missed it with the first one
and he's like he's about like maybe 40
feet above me in the air and the second
arrow [ __ ] nailed the eagle both of
them fall down
oh you hit the eagle but the goat died
too oh well yeah
both of them he was he was alive when
the eagle dropped him yeah when he hit
the ground
before we get into the nitty-gritty i
feel like i really really like this game
because i was not expecting to like it i
feel like my expectation this is like
one of those expectation games where
they kind of
jumped us on it we didn't know much
about it i think they only announced in
october of last year yeah and then i
wasn't really too hot on it didn't we
know what it was and then when i started
playing i was like oh this is actually
like really interesting and like very
different in terms of a first person
game do you think that's
is that any reason why you think you
enjoyed it so much yeah i mean
i remember when they first announced it
i think a lot of us were questioning is
oh is this just another blood dragon
sized kind of spin-off and that would
have been good but then they're like oh
no it's 60 so then that's when people
start getting apprehensive and after
playing it yeah it's a full game it it
does not feel just like
it it's a reskin in a few ways but
that's being kind of disingenuous
because it does a lot of its own things
really well but it's
yeah i think that factored into how i
was really pleasantly surprised have
like how much it feels very much like
its own thing separate from three and
four um i i think going back i loved
three four i was already getting tired
of it there's such a long game yeah four
i was kind of already having fatigue so
i think if they needed to do something
new this was the time because
it really is its own thing and like that
was one of the my favorite parts about
the game uh it really sticks to the
setting that they chose to go with and
on almost every layer so it feels like
an old farco game and the fact that this
is a game where you're like going out
and taking over outposts and you're
upgrading yourself and your skeleton
also in what way is it does it not feel
like a fracker and what game does it
feel like its own thing it's very much
uh more focused on survival not as bad
as much as like don't starve or the long
dark it's not um that's not its main
conceit it's but it's it is a survival
enough where you're thinking about it
constantly it's uh it's a good balance
between trying to survive but also
you're still having fun it's not just
like dire all the time uh you know you
go into the frozen north and there's a
cold meter that kind of keeps uh falling
down and yeah if you're not if you don't
have a torch lit in front of you or
you're not near a bonfire you have to
manage because you're you're just
wearing like fur and a loincloth
which you know just put on more clothes
you'll be fine but you don't always have
you can't just put on like raw you can't
just leave your way into a horse there
you go this is the perfect time to give
advice as dr bruhl and yeah look to the
camera for your health hey kill horse
climb inside you dingus
whatever but he that was a bad steve
real impression
you uh yeah no it's it's really it feels
right no one's gonna chop that out yeah
yeah but
the setting the setting itself is it
becomes a detriment at certain points
because
it's it's true the setting it's
primitive it's the stone age your tool
set is limited and it's this is when
supposedly you know this is around when
humans started making tools or at least
a little bit after
don't quote me on that don't worry about
it but it's not why people are here yeah
but it but the fact that they kind of
like stick to those same six weapons and
then you get like variations on them
it does it feels like it fits really
well um whether it is always fun or not
is not like i didn't think that was the
case but after a while i kind of really
appreciated how much it really stuck to
the stone age um we got a bunch of
questions from folks here obviously we
got to play the game for well over a
week so let's jump into it and see if we
can answer some of these uh blackrain
zero on twitter says uh how random are
the enemy encounters in this world uh do
i need to be always watching my back
uh you're kind of
tense the whole time for sure it's you
know like especially at night there's a
day night cycle that's another thing
that happens oh yeah predators are more
aggressive and abundant and they're
different predators at night there's
certain like rare animals you have to
hunt at night but there are
you know like fire factors into it a lot
so i always want to have a club to light
it to make a torch because if there are
predators coming up on you from behind
you just swing it and like especially
wolves will freak out with fire certain
animals won't be as affected by it
they'll run away and come back like a
saber tooth will
you know consider you and then walk away
yeah a bear don't give a [ __ ] it's like
the saber-tooth the bear will just be
like i'm leaving or no the saber's too
big i'm leaving but it's because i want
to not because you're telling me too the
bear yeah will just be like i don't know
i can set a bear on fire and they're
like you come out the fire yeah yeah
they don't care they're like i'm a
flaming bear now yeah now it just made
me
way cooler and more dangerous
it's uh yeah so i was pretty constantly
watching my back i know you were saying
you were surprised at how like little
you were sprinting because you were kind
of worried
you're just gonna come across a pack of
wolves it's really cool the wolves
traveling packs the tigers hunt alone
it's again it's very at nighttime all
the pumas come out and it's like yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah that was the thing
because i was wondering how big the map
was and what the traversal was going to
be like because like far cry games are i
mean like one of them had a bloody
helicopter you were like flying around
in like there are games about trying to
get to the far away place whereas the
momentum it was like it was like it's
not about the destination it's the
journey that's what this one felt like
where actually it was interesting going
from place to place because you couldn't
like just sprint through an area because
like i was sprinting through areas and i
turn and a bear was there and you can't
just kill a bear and you can't even
outrun a bear you need to like figure
out a way of getting away from it and i
thought that was incredible because and
at the start like super scary because
literally everything could kill you yeah
and then the interesting thing was when
you do all the beastmaster stuff and you
train a beast to be your buddy then for
instance if you have like a big cat and
that scares away all the yeah like
wolves and stuff and so it's one less
thing to have to worry about sure which
is pretty cool and that's the
beastmaster abilities are
probably my favorite part of the game
especially when you start doing the
legendary beast hunts with a
forget the name of the hunter she like
she gives you specific missions to go on
to get the blood fang saber tooth the
blood tusk mammoth the uh
the scar bear or something i got the
saber tooth which helped me hunt all the
other ones but yeah you eventually
i
they're kind of the power weapons of far
cry primal in like grenade launchers or
rocket launchers absence because there
are legendary pistols and whatnot but
you you know they become an extension of
yourself you could tell them to go
attack a certain uh enemy udom or azila
the other caveman
um or uh just hunt like big mammoths
because mammoths take forever to bring
down if you're just using spears but if
you have the blood fang sabertooth with
you it's it's pretty cool like when the
mammoth closes dying it's close to dying
the same people like climb on top and
then just bring it down just destroying
it and then i think rob said he saw
it grab a bore and pull its head back
and just like eat its throat oh yeah
yeah which i i want to see that but
yeah that's again and the beastmaster
billy just kind of feed into that
setting a little more i
cavemen couldn't control animals like
that but it's
still a cool way to yeah i know i talked
to you about this a little bit i really
wish you could make animals hunt for
food for you yeah right yeah like see
your owl give me a squirrel real quick
not squirrels but you can have the saber
tooth say like
go kill that boar
yeah you need to skin it but they won't
like retrieve you can't be like i'm
going to do this thing you go get me
some food don't worry about it no it's
not like it's not like a pet companion
from what was that torchlight yeah
that's fair i don't think the game needs
it but like that would be so enticing to
me yeah it would make because crafting
and hunting are such huge parts and that
was it does get a little here's a tip
actually like a quality of life tip in
the options you can turn off the
um retrieval animations so you don't
have to bend down and wait for him to
finish skinning the animals
and now you just go up and the branch
disappears the animal just becomes vegan
yeah actually yeah if anyone from
ubisoft is listening actually
i was about to say red dead redemption
i'd love to have that there's a great
exchange happening in the chat here um
uh heap gamer said i wonder if can you
farm in the game to which game delay
replies a couple of thousand years too
early for that unfortunately he got him
so it is historically accurate so yeah
let's get into a couple of more
questions you have you actually if you
don't mind anthony dealio asks never
been into far cry but i like the setting
of primal enough to consider it do you
think non-far cry fans would enjoy this
yeah because i think saying something
has a far cry formula there's so many
different games that kind of use that
formula even like it shares a lot of
things with just cause two and three
those are third person and just more
destruction but it's still kind of
taking out posts to start covering the
map and opening up waypoints at a
certain point this just becomes its very
own thing because it's you know it's
that survival it's that kind of
primitive time period
not that many games have done like you
know the stone age like that's a
different thing to arc as well that's
not like that right yeah there's no
people there's no dinosaurs here there's
no it's just it's very uh
it's simplified almost and i think it's
very much better for it and i think
people who
want a far cry experience will get that
but also people
like the person asking the question will
have a very singular like experience
with just playing this uh andy kelly
just asked us to saw the question come
up about the pc version unfortunately we
haven't played it yet so we can't say uh
speak to that yet we've got a question
here from our good friend kevin van hord
who says hey mike i have a question does
this game benefit from its caveman
language slash subtitles as a creative
choice so this game they actually seem
to have gone through quite a large
amount of efforts to create pre
like
proto latin languages or whatever like
pre-human super early languages yeah
pre-human but pre-language i don't know
whatever [ __ ] languages linguistics
uh
does that work like i felt like the the
the really good facial animation they
had in far cry 3 and 4 was like so much
more useful than this because out of a
[ __ ] clue these people are saying but
they're like selling it with their
emotions yeah well that's that's the
same thing here um i don't
know that they needed to devote that
much time to making their own languages
here like i have no idea hopefully
obviously i've noticed the game less or
more if they all are cockney language
accents um
very much more or like russian accents
or
just as if each tribe had some sort of
weird just like hey i'm a pirate huh i
don't know what was it what was that
this is that's his
defense the step brothers sleepwalking
oh hi i'm carol like there's running
around the open world uh yeah no i think
it grounds the setting a little more and
uh
it it serves it creatively as far as
each tribe has their own language so you
know the udom have this guttural thing
these zila have a little more uh of a
kind of uh
attractive language i guess and then the
you know like kind of just whinging yeah
i don't know that i'd recognize one if i
heard it the udom is pretty distinct and
like how guttural it is
people at conventions like using these
languages
becomes like a major
university across yeah
they'll have weddings
yeah udon noodles for the dinner so yeah
i liked it though it helped establish
the tone a little more it feels like a
really unique world because like even
the the areas you're in the like crazy
valleys and like glacial yeah like it
just feels like something completely new
uh tim laro asked a good question
actually kind of to that point uh from
the trailers it looks pretty brown does
the open world have much diversity i
think he is talking about environmental
and not racial sure so everything looked
like it was very much a
you know
temperate
forest rainforest yeah so
how much more diversity in terms of the
environment is there within that map and
how big is the map actually there is uh
so the map they're saying the game
itself is comparable in size to four the
map is definitely not as big as four is
huge again because you had helicopters
and what not but it is uh primal is very
much
especially given how slowly you traverse
the map sometimes not in a tedious way
um
it you run you come across these areas
where the forest is just all burned and
that plays into the story a little bit
um however much of a story there is um
and then you go into the the northern
part where it's snowy and then you're in
these like frozen frozen caves you go
into the swamp and then that becomes you
know they're alligators and just like
underwater predators everywhere so not
only does it look diverse but it also
kind of feels diverse based on where you
are with those kind of different
survival aspects
uh great question here as well from
couchdave93
are there caveman beer drinking games
how much of the like fun little weird
caveman stuff is there and i'm mostly
asking this because i want to ask you
about the [ __ ] scenes
oh the okay i see what you're saying i
didn't come across as much as rob did no
uh rob had some
luck or bad luck how are you looking at
coming across these intimate parts with
that there are there are multiple yeah
sex things happening between the cave
people yeah they're they're definitely
like during the main story there's a few
allusions to stuff like that but i've i
was not
fortunate enough to just stumble upon
them
i got reached out by one of the uh
developers at ubisoft montreal who
apparently had worked on the animations
for the sex scenes really and i asked
him about the mocap and he was like yeah
we did mocap like
they were ever super uncomfortable for
the people doing it is that like shia
labeouf actually had sex for the movie
uh nymphomaniac oh did he really yeah
like he actually they shot them i'm not
surprised entry is a really weird dude
i'm not surprised yeah that's anyway
we're getting a little bit off topic
here um
yeah so there you go
far cry primal yeah it's good it's a
great game
what's up dude
what is that it's a dumb thing it's a
really good vine to feel good
so like every time i see someone outside
so do it and everybody else does it back
because like it's spread like wildfire
god damn wildfire i would have worked
better about frock right too
it's a shame yeah you can't set stuff on
fire in this one yeah you can set
yourself on fire you said there is on
fire in fact i set this up all the
you said a lot of when you start
fighting the azila tribe it's all fire
right and there are certain animals that
are more resistant to fire yeah
abilities
no oh [ __ ] out
yeah actually okay so when we have our
like morning meetings on a monday and we
go through like all the statistics for
like how everything did the previous
week and how you know what's trafficking
and whatnot one of the things that keeps
getting googled is far cry dinosaurs
yeah
are the dinosaurs in this game no there
is a dragon though oh really it's dead
um there's a skeleton of a dragon it's a
blood dragon cool easter egg rob and
i'll check it out during the stream
after this okay yes in fact we are doing
a stream right after this for uh far cry
primal so stick around apparently
there's an assassin's creed easter egg
which i have not found myself but i'm
gonna i might look it up just to see
where it is see it in person find the
skeleton of that franchise just lying on
it
no it's not screaming this year
right yeah probably watch dogs all
right watch dogs too i think so oh yeah
i think so but yeah that's actually
that's what's interesting in san
francisco probably from what i hear yeah
the rumor the rumor mills that they were
around town last year so
we'll see about that stop by uh cbsi say
what's up the gamespot crew i'm sure
they did that when they're doing a
secret super secret yeah looking around
san francisco no i'm saying in the game
stop by and see what's up yeah yeah
hang out hack peter's computer see what
he's been searching yeah my password is
butts i could i could do that was that
two have done that while you were
well if i told you then it wouldn't be
easy
but t3 sorry what are we going to say
before i rudely interrupted uh yeah
that's why i think primal is
what ubisoft needed in the short term
because or i guess long term because
they don't have a new assassin's creed
this year as far as the big aaa
experience goes i think primals kind of
maybe the shot in the arm they needed to
kind of keep things fresh
yes
which is that next month sorry as far as
their established franchises go i should
have mentioned yeah i wonder if it'll
sell because part of me is like worried
that like all their promotion for this
game was like about the beastmaster and
team the animals like hunting which is
like kind of like a
you know i feel like that would play
really well in america maybe with like
certain crowds like yeah okay like that
that type of thing but like i wonder how
much of a hit they take why not like
it's great that they did this like all
powered
you know to ubisoft for taking the risk
on this and i think they've done a
pretty good job but like i wonder how
much of a hit they take financially when
a game doesn't have a gun on the box
right no that's a real consideration i'm
sure that they talked about it could be
just a chance for them to test the
waters
with whatever things they've learned
from the past few games helping them at
least make it a more efficient
development cycle right i don't know but
yeah we do that was part of it yeah i
wonder how long they were working on
this as well considering we only found
out about it in october nine months
before coming over oh sorry like what
how many months was it before it
released that we found out about it yeah
it was like six or four yeah really
short that's really hard to gauge though
like in terms of when the things started
right because fallout 4 is in
development for years right yeah
six months late time yeah i like it
yeah less work for us to do kind of but
also kind of better less anticipation
yeah yeah
yeah thanks mike thanks for coming in
thanks answering the questions from our
good friends in the twitch gamespot chat
and via twitter and that's a show that's
almost a show let's have a quick little
chin wag about what we're doing actually
we had you on for fire emblem a couple
of times uh over the past weeks uh those
three reviews went up they did so yes
people were able to check out the the
three there was it was conquests birth
rights earth right and then the other
one that's coming out uh revelation
revelation is coming uh some people a
bit unhappy about the conquest the
review of conquest they thought that you
were being critical of
of the
mechanics they'd made i guess what were
you saying i said each of your
housekeeping oh
yeah i mean i can't really talk about
this without sounding defensive sorry
i'm going to sound like i'm right now
yeah
uh
people had problems with my review
because uh my biggest criticism of the
game is that they don't let you grind
for experience yeah that was the you
could in the other two right you can in
the other two conquest and grinding to
me serves two purposes one it helps you
you know level up your crew so they're
stronger
but it also allows you to sort of
explore things in the game
that you know
that if you just follow the linear story
path you wouldn't really encounter
especially something like fire emblem
where there's like classes and skills
and relationships involved like there's
a lot of things to tap into conquest
because it's so linear doesn't allow you
to do those things right
um
and yeah i don't know like people seem
to think that i said the game was too
hard
uh but they were also critical of the
fact that i played it with in classic
mode of permadeath right where i didn't
reset the game
which to me was just mind-boggling and
this was coming from the really
passionate fire emblem fans and i don't
mean to affront your tastes at all like
and i liked conquest i gave it a seven
but i felt that
by trying to create this really focused
experience in a game that is part of a
trilogy that sort of shares so many
things in common this one was devoid of
so much of the content that makes a
modern fire emblem game interesting and
this is a modern fire emblem so there
were people saying like to play devil's
advocate were people saying that like oh
this is sort of harkening back to fire
emblems of old and yeah and it does seem
like a mechanic that would constrain
would like i don't know like control the
difficulty a little bit totally and i
made it two-thirds of the way through
the game on classic difficulty without
resetting to save any revived characters
before i got to the point where i was
like
i i'm playing the same mission over and
over i can't get through it
if only i could grind all i can do is
turn the game down to casual into easy
mode uh and so that was another thing i
felt like i was penalized for sticking
with the the permadeath aspect
um
and again people were telling me that
you have to play it like a strategy game
pete it's like oh thank you for telling
me i didn't realize this was a strategy
game like i think you know i i was
pretty diligent the whole time it was
tough but more than that like i just i
wanted the opportunity to develop more
relationships and develop my team and
where some people said well maybe that
would make the game too easy my answer
to that is well the enemies can scale
with you that's another question uh so
you know anyway like i still think
conquest was great and i'm seven out of
ten right yeah and i apologize my review
wasn't clear enough but like but really
i think people should consider the fact
that as much as this is trying to be a
classic fire emblem game it's coming out
like along two really modern games
and
again they share things that just
aren't really as accessible in this one
it's a super interesting way to release
games i think like i i wish i was a fan
of that series like i'd love for one of
my favorite franchises to release like
three different
ideas like three different flavors of
the same game it's super interesting
it's interesting but i think you can
accomplish the same thing by providing
alternate narrative paths or
options in the game you know like turn
off grinding turn off anything you want
the fireball once you customize so many
things right at this point it's sort of
like and the fact that they're forcing
this this harder version out is its own
version is is kind of just an excuse to
have more products i mean aren't they
doing some dlc as well down the line
that's gonna there's a bunch of deals
there's a bunch of dlc but you have to
pay for it right so if i'm paying for
the privilege of grinding to earn
experience in one game when i get it in
the box with the other game wait i'm
actually going to apply grinding to
conquest yeah you buy things called
experience missions oh you can't really
yes
they're available in all of all the
versions of the game yeah oh okay but is
that a bit weird
it's not a bit like hey here's that
thing you might have wanted sorry i
didn't realize that this was a yeah
yeah it's a weird it's a weird scenario
um i think like i applaud nintendo for
taking
you know the the chance to do something
like this but again you know you ordered
the special edition of the game if you
were lucky enough to be one of those
people to get in right when it was
announced you get all three games on one
cart yeah so it was possible they chose
not to do it
and you know for anyone who buys
conquest not knowing what they're
getting into right they might find
themselves you know with a little bit of
buyer's remorse and then their only
alternative is to return the game for
less than they bought it for
or purchase the other version yeah you
know as dlc and and that's too bad when
i think you know the special edition
proves that they can all fit on one cart
and everyone can have everything if they
really wanted to yeah cool all right
thank you so much that's probably the
last time i'll get you to talk about
firearms on the show for a little while
actually until the next one's out until
oh i guess you've already covered the
review we've covered yeah we've covered
that review yeah i mean firewall is
awesome i love it yeah i just want more
of it there's been so many good games
coming out this year already it's like
we're not even gdc time it's
mid-february and we've already had like
bunches of great games coming out this
used to be the dead zone it seems to be
like nothing comes out in january and
then subs kind of warms up around
february people got money in their
wallets again but a bunch of great stuff
yeah yeah yeah i mean i've got so much
more far cry primal to play as well yeah
at this stage what are you working on
the moment mike before we wrap it up um
playing like
dark souls soon just for
like a thing before release yeah check
it out one more time uh other than that
just real soon yeah uh other than that
i'll probably play more primal uh zelda
twilight princess i'm a huge zelda fan
uh so i'm really looking forward to uh
playing more of that i got to uh the the
first dungeon past those two
hours which are pretty tough to uh
to stomach especially in like in
retrospect remember i always knew they
were kind of cloying but playing it
again is
tough yeah but it looks really good and
uh it's like i was playing on the the
gamepad for a while but now i'm playing
on the pro controller it just feels a
little better sweet yeah and then other
than that just rocket league while i
listen to taylor swift
oh uh having a barbecue party this
weekend you should stop by just moved
out to the new place oh yeah yeah
congratulations
thank you so much everyone you moved in
in like a game spot pad yeah half the
office works there or lives a few of us
yeah and probably works there
yeah
yeah i'm getting some work done but uh
yeah
that's where i come by you say rocket
league yeah and i've already got like my
stomach's already starting to turn
because we've got the finals on today
yeah
i'm missing it unfortunately but i'll go
back and watch it in the archive i'm
sure yeah the pro-am which we've been
running if you didn't know we've been
running on a game spot for the past i
don't know for like two months i feel
like josh has been knocking the scene
together basically like uh people who
play rocket league and people who don't
play rocket league kind of buddy up 2v2
style um and it's chris pereira matt
paget against eric tay and ryan schubert
yeah in the losers bracket final and
then whoever wins that plays myself in
julio in a 5v5 in the grand final i'm
sorry i have a five round best of five
yeah 2v2 i'm so nervous because i've
been playing so bad all weekend peat
night would probably be at this point if
we didn't both take a dive for money
sure completely in our power to keep
winning but we just decided against it
i'm hoping josh like throws a curveball
and we end up playing on like that donut
level or something that'd be great just
like completely those ones are fun not
my preferred but they're fun i like that
they're there yeah it's like when you
get unreal tournament you just
you don't you don't do level lord
missions in like competitive play but
yeah let's all [ __ ] shoot each other
in a massive kitchen yeah just for a
couple minutes it's fun right here's the
simpsons house great it's a nice break
from reality yeah stop taking it so
seriously video games come on uh thank
you both for coming on mike maherty
peter brown scott butlerworth who uh who
has uh left us he's off doing other
things and thank you so much to everyone
who's been reviewing uh the lobby on
itunes and all of your eye
things all of your podcasts machine
doohickeys see it's not even that like
i'm not in tune with podcasting it's a
podcast i can't believe podcasting's
still around
yeah well i but you know what though
like audio is so convenient you can
listen to it while you're doing almost
anything else i know i listen like more
podcast now than i have in my entire
life yeah but for a while they're like
like i was like came and gone yeah but
no that's the beauty of them yeah and so
many people are listening to this show
so thank you so much i know it took us a
while to do it uh thanks to all the
folks uh jeff and mr berrier and
ohiodesigner9 and kakarsk and bry210 i
love it even on itunes people which is
like something you tend to have like you
know you spend money on that they've
still got ridiculous names on that as
well yeah so yeah i appreciate it if
you're listening to the show if you're
watching it at all and you're on itunes
feel free to rate and review us uh we
really appreciate it uh thank you that's
the show for this week we'll be back
next tuesday thanks again to everyone in
the back for producing this show andy
bowman behind that steadicam give us a
little bit of wobble
give us a little bit look at that oh
yeah yeah shake those hips [ __ ]
uh josh shaw on the back and mary kish
back there as well everyone putting this
show together really appreciate it we
will be back tuesday 2 p.m pacific sorry
eric today i forgot about you there i'm
richard as well we've got everyone a lot
of people working the show uh we'll be
back tuesday 2pm pacific eric's hovering
that finger over the close button let's
see if we'll get it right we'll see you
then bye stick around far cry primal
stream right after this
you